it's the year 478 BCE and an interesting
Embassy of various diplomats presents
itself to the Athenian assembly this
video is sponsored by the great courses
plus but more on that later this embassy
that presented itself before the
Athenian assembly well actually they
would first come before the preteen eyes
who were part of the pool who would
decide whether to present them before
the assembly but the Athenian government
is all but not simple so for simplicity
sake let's just say the embassy
presented itself before the assembly
this embassy was a coalition of various
Greek Ionian city-states but also most
likely other Greek city-states were part
of it as well and they all came to
Athens to present before the Athenians
their plea for Athens to take the
leadership of the Hellenic Alliance away
from the Spartans why is there a
Hellenic Alliance why are the Spartans
leading it why are the Ionians asking
Athens to help and how is this all even
related to the creation of the Athenian
Empire well let's get into it before 478
the Hellenic world was embroiled in a
conflict the scale of which they have
never seen before the Persian Empire
ruling over most of Eastern known world
had set its sights on Greece and so the
conflict known as the greco-persian Wars
started I do not intend to cover this
entire topic as that would require an
entire video series of its own but it's
important to mention certain events from
it that led to the arrival of the
aforementioned diplomatic embassy to
Athens and 478 so the simplified version
goes like this
the greco-persian Wars started with a
rebellion of Ionian Greeks against the
Persian rule and 499 they were supported
in this rebellion by Athenians and
eretrians
the revolt was subdued by the Persians
and 493 but the Persian King Darius
vowed to make athens and eretria pay for
their support of the revolt and so with
this in mind he invaded Greece in 490
where he was promptly defeated in
marathon by mainly Athenian but also
some Eritrean forces led by callimachus
during the battle callimachus was
supported by 10 strategery basically
Athenian generals the most important of
which were arrested 'is Themistocles
Sanofi pose and of course milites
milites was the one to pressure the
Athenians to face the Persians in open
battle and he was the one who devised
the battle tactic that defeated
the Persians even though they are
numbered Athenians after the battle the
story goes that the remaining Persians
wanted to use their fleet to attack
Athens since the Athenian army was in
Marathon but the Athenians marched as
fast as they could in a full armored 40
kilometers from Marathon to Athens just
in time to see the Persian fleet
arriving who upon seeing the Athenian
army in the city decided to retreat this
story was later romanticized and
confused with a different story
resulting in the story we know today
which is that after the Athenian
victories marathon a herald cult
Philippa Dee's was dispatched to
announce the news in Athens he ran the
full 40 kilometres an armored exclaimed
before the assembly we have won and
promptly died of exhaustion this story
is why today's marathon is called the
marathon and widest 40 kilometers long
well not exactly but I digress after
depression defeated marathon a year
later military's LaDainian troops on the
offensive but this proved to be not so
successful and he even managed to get
grievously injured during this campaign
his rivals and Athens used this failed
campaign and other arguments to get
militaries imprisoned this man who
helped Athens defeat the Persians at
marathon died due to his injuries while
being imprisoned by said Athenians he
was also almost ostracized if he had
lived a couple of years longer to see
this new law come into practice what is
ostracism well for those who don't know
ostracism was an Athenian way of getting
rid of people who might be aspiring to
overthrow the democracy if more than
6,000 votes were cast it who's ever name
was mentioned the most in those 6000
plus votes was exiled from Athens for a
period of 10 years the problem with this
was that even though the reason why the
ostracism was introduced was quite
altruistic it just ended up being in
another way of getting rid of your
political rivals and almost anyone who
became popular in Athenian politics get
ostracized eventually even the person
who introduced ostracism and reformed
Athenian democracy to be more democratic
glaced anis
is said to have been ostracized himself
maybe the sources aren't clear but it is
known that his son was later ostracized
so a little foreshadowing there of how
it ends for most of the people
these videos going back to the
greco-persian Wars Darius was preparing
another invasion of Greece but died in
486 and was succeeded by his son Xerxes
Xerxes had to deal with rebellions and
consolidate his power within Persia and
due to this he put his father's planned
Greek invasion on hold until 480 during
this ten-year interbellum in the war two
prominent politicians came to ascendance
and Athens the veterans of the Battle of
Marathon Themistocles and our stds
Themistocles was popular with the lower
classes mainly because he came from them
he was known as a cunning man who always
had a plan and to whom sometimes the
ends did justify the means
IRA studies on the other hand positioned
himself against the mystical ease he was
the champion of the upper classes called
the just arrested ease by his supporters
he was incorruptible conservative and
has full dark puts it he was in politics
to secure the best results consistent
with safety and righteousness not to be
a populist nonetheless the main issue
these two disagreed on was whether
Athens should focus more on its Navy or
its military with the mystically
supporting the former and arrested East
ladder this heated debate culminated in
483 when a very rich seam of silver was
found in the Athenian controlled mines
of Laurium Themistocles wanted to use
the newfound money to build a great new
Navy for Athens while our studies
fearing this would mean Athens
abandonment of its military in favor of
the Navy proposed dividing up the money
amongst Athenian citizens at the end it
looked like a compromise was going to be
reached between the two sides but an
ostracism was held in this time during
the ostracism and a literate man came up
to our studies not recognizing him he
asked Aristides if he could please write
the name arrested 'yes on his pottery
shard which was the ballot confused our
studies asked the man has arrested his
wrongs you at any point to which the man
replied no and I do not even know him
but it irritates me to hear him
everywhere called the just our studies
then true to his nickname brought his
own name on the pottery shard and
surprisingly our studies was ostracized
meaning Themistocles won and Athens
promptly started to build one of the
largest fleets in the Aegean and 481
learned of the plan persian invasion and
so called for a greek council they were
around 700 greek city-states at the time
but only 70 showed up to the council
however even with that it has to be
stated how big of a deal this is even
ten percent of the greek city-states
showing up to a council when some of
them are technically in an active war
with each other is impressive the
council decided a hellenic alliance with
the power to levy troops and sent
ambassadors would be formed to fight the
persians this hellenic alliance promptly
made the spartans the main leaders of
the alliance and of the joint military
because i mean it's the war obsessed
spartans who else should lead the Allies
to war the athenians on the other hand
with their fancy new big navy and due to
some clever diplomatic maneuvering by
Themistocles managed to be appointed as
the leaders of the Allied Navy and so
with athenian Themistocles leading the
Navy and Spartan Leonidas the military
what follows next are the stories of
legends Persians win at Thermopylae
killing Leonidas and marched to Attica
to burn down Athens along with a bunch
of other cities and temples along the
way most Athenians however retreated
with the hellenic alliance to the
isthmus of corinth so they were safe for
now also athens during this time passed
a law of recalling exiles meaning our
studies could return and so he did
promptly serving under Themistocles in
the Allies Navy also since Leonidas was
dead he was promptly succeeded in the
leadership of the Allies by another
Spartan Pausanias the Persian Navy was
then defeated thanks to Themistocles
cunning at the Battle of Salamis after
that the Allies went on the offensive
defeating the invading forces at the
Battle of Plataea and remaining Persian
Navy at the Battle of michalak during
the Battle of Plataea our studies showed
his confidence
orator skills and honor even helping to
put down a conspiracy within the army
these actions gave the Allies great
admiration for STD's but more on that
later
with the Persian threat no longer
imminent Athenians returned to their
burnt down and destroyed city they
promptly started to rebuild their city
along with the destroyed walls naturally
the Spartans objected to the Athenians
rebuilding their walls because well they
didn't want their main rival to have
walls
Themistocles however ever the trickster
devised
the plan of how to trick the Spartans he
told the Athenians to focus on only
building the walls as quick as they can
he then headed an embassy to Sparta
along with a man named ki-moon where he
delayed for as long as he could
Spartans however didn't believe his
words and so Themistocles suggested the
Spartans and invoice of their own to see
for themselves of Athenians are building
the walls or not he then himself sent a
herald to Athens telling them to keep
hostage to Spartan invoice that will
arrive the Athenians did so and when our
stds arrived to sparta to inform
Themistocles that the walls have been
finished enraged Spartans wanted to
imprison the entire Athenian embassy to
which Themistocles nicely pointed out
they had the Spartan invoice in custody
in Athens so the Spartans reluctantly
released the Athenian Embassy and the
Athenians released a Spartan embassy
before leaving the mystic Lee's informed
the Spartans for future reference that
Athenians weren't just any Greek city
the Spartans could boss around and in
fact it was a city of distinguished
people which could make their own
decisions without Spartan or any other
city's consent
the new Athenian walls on top of
encompassing a much larger area than the
actual city itself were also built
around the new Athenian port bureaus
Themistocles couldn't stress enough how
valuable having access to the sea was
for the Athenians now that they were the
dominant naval power in the Greek world
he even suggested that if worse comes to
worse the athenians abandoned their city
in favor of defending Piraeus whether
that will ever happen I guess we'll just
have to see going back to the
greco-persian wars the hellenic alliance
continued being on the offensive taking
over Gallipoli raiding Cyprus and
capturing Byzantium all while most of
the Ionian Greeks remember them rebelled
from the Persians again and joined the
Alliance however during this entire time
the Spartans were the ones in charge of
the Alliance actions after all as
mentioned before you're going to war
with the largest empire in the known
world so you probably want to make the
war upset Spartans the leaders of the
Alliance but now that the imminent
threat of Persian invasion of Greece has
been largely stifled the problems of
Spartan hegemony are starting to come to
light the Spartan leader of the Alliance
Polonius was said to be dictatorial
violent corrupt and even often
irrational now these statements may have
been just Athenian propaganda at play
but considering that Spartans were known
for carrying sticks and beating with
them anyone who disagreed with their
opinion it would be easy to assume that
the Sandia's wasn't really liked by the
Allied troops which brings us back to
478 and the Allied Embassy coming to
Athens pleading for them to take over
the leadership of the Alliance Athenians
agreed to take the leadership away from
the Spartans under certain conditions
the exact details of this and how the
new alliance was run is a matter of
debate because no source talks about it
in detail but to present the coherent
story I'm going to go with ngl Hammonds
representation each Li will swear an
oath to the gods to have an offensive
and the defensive alliance with Athens
also sometimes to the Alliance itself as
a whole depends
it will also be required to participate
in the Alliance's Council on the island
of Delos each ally has a seat and one
vote on the council however the Athenian
vote is equivalent to the whole
alliances council vote
Plus Athens will hold a permanent
hegemony over the leadership of the
Alliance's Navy and Army on top of that
any booty gotten from raiding and
pillaging the Persian territory will be
divided amongst allies and of course
1/10 of it will go to the gods lastly
each ally has to either support the
alliance and military / naval aid or
financial payments which would be held
at a Treasury in Delos why Delos you ask
well partly because it's conveniently
placed in the middle of the Aegean
partly because it's an island and so
easily defendable by the Athenian Navy
and partly because it is a very
religiously important site in the
Hellenic world it is the island where
the twin gods of apollo and artemis were
born and came down from the mountain of
kintu's having the allies meet at such a
religiously important place would make
them think twice before breaking the
oath they swore to Athens before the
gods most allies mainly the Islanders
and the Ionians agree to these terms
while others like Sparta just select the
Alliance why Sparta give up the hegemony
of the Alliance is uncertain but it is
mostly agreed that they felt like the
Persians have been soundly defeated and
there was no longer a reason to continue
on with the Alliance this combined with
the Athenian restructuring of the
Alliance meant that not everybody was
happy being part of the Alliance anymore
why did the other allies agree to the
terms set by Athens well for the Ionians
and some Islanders this was a perfect
deal as they were in a constant threat
from Persia and so being part of such an
alliance with one of the most powerful
cities in the Greek world meant
protection other cities even at this
early point may have been strong-armed
by Athens into joining the new alliance
but we have no way of knowing that for
sure lastly there's an economic aspect
to it
being part of the Alliance means
protection stability and more
streamlined access to markets something
which the trade oriented thatthose would
enjoy so in 478 the Athenians became the
leaders of a newly created Alliance
which henceforth we shall call the
Delian League a political entity which
gradually over the course of the fifth
century became the Athenian Empire so
now that Athens is leading this new
Delian League what are they going to do
about the Persian threat also what is
the mystical ease and rs to these role
in this new league plus
was the new guy named ki-moon who helped
the mystically stricte Spartans all very
good questions that are going to be
answered in the next video of my
Athenian Empire series however if you
can't wait for that video because let's
be honest I don't even know when the
next video in this series is going to
come out you can always go to the great
courses plus and go on a deep dive of
Athenian history for example if you want
to learn how that complicated democratic
government of Athens actually worked
then a series by an actual history
professor all about Athenian democracy
it explains what we don't know about the
democracy what we know and some current
theories about it as well it's so
detailed it's it's great and you don't
have to stick to just classical history
because oh my god there's so many videos
on so many story topics on the great
courses plus not to even mention all the
non history videos there's so many of
them too for example as an amateur
musician myself I found this lecture on
how playing music affects your brain
very fascinating I highly recommend it
so if you want to get a free trial to
learn some new things go to the great
courses plus calm slash Emma laser
history or click the link right in the
description
you